sure smartphones have come a long way
but the included email apps on them
don't feel like they've moved an inch
I can't tell someone my schedule attach
files or create reminders to follow up
on something without straining my thumbs
and I'm not the only one that feels this
way since more startups than you sound
are trying to solve the mobile email
problem no really
more startups than you can account just
last week another app for the coffee was
released for the iPhone but are any of
these iPhone and Android apps actually
giving us what we want in mobile email
the answer is yes but no single one is
doing it all the first thing I want from
an email app better and smarter
composing tons of apps for the iPhone do
a better job of letting you attach a
photo or a document than the regular
iPhone email app it's actually
embarrassing but the accompli iPhone app
goes even further letting you attach
your photos files even your location and
the times you're available right from
inside the compose window it does this
by integrating your Gmail or exchange
calendar right in the app there's no
accompli for Android yet but mailbox
cloud magic and my mail which are out
for Android and iPhone are also good for
attachments
I just wish cloud magic and mailbox let
users save draft emails it drives me
nuts the second thing I want to be able
to easily file emails or remember that
when I have time to respond that's what
the mailbox app from Dropbox is all
about you can add an email to its do
list or have it remind you about an
email at a later time or date the trick
will get better when mailbox launches
its Mac app you'll be able to tell the
phone to remind you of a message when
you're at your computer
the downside mailbox only works with
Gmail and Apple's iCloud accounts cloud
magic also lets you set message
reminders but it's real standout feature
is the ability to save the contents of
your email the app scans your messages
and suggest saving specific content to
different apps for instance you can save
an article that was sent to you to a
read later app like pocket or an
important to do write to Evernote
I know I'm starting to sound like that
spoiled girl from Willy Wonka but I want
all of that and better email search also
Golden Goose cloud magic does a great
job at quickly searching your contacts
in the full-text of everything in your
inbox an app called gusto creates a tab
for each kind of attachment so you can
sift through all the photos people have
sent you on one tab and then word
documents on another a comple does
something similar problem is both are
only available for the iPhone email on
your mobile phone may still be a broken
experience but these apps are slowly
improving it cloud magic comes the
closest to being the best overall
solution with its reminders improved
search and the ability to talk to apps
that are already making your life easier
it also runs on iPhone and Android and
works with many email services at the
very least these apps and cloud magic
will help with the phone strain